well Democrats and Republicans are
condemning president Trump's abrupt
decision to withdraw all US ground
troops from Syria the president tweeted
this morning it's time for other nations
to fight Isis depending on officials and
the State Department are scrambling to
get troops equipment and diplomats out
of war-torn Syria safely senior US
officials said last week that Isis holds
one percent of the territory it once
held but that's not the whole story the
Pentagon estimates there are still up to
30,000 Isis fighters in Syria the
president declared victory on Twitter
against the advice of his top national
security advisors just two weeks ago the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
said only 20% of local forces have been
trained to fight against Isis CBS News
senior global affairs contributor Ian
Bremmer is president of Eurasia Group
good morning and Casillas so we have two
issues there's a situation with Isis and
then there is Russia and Iran in Syria
let me start with that second piece what
happens if the u.s. is out of Syria what
kind of vacuum does that create not very
much to be completely honest with you I
mean look Assad has won
President Obama said Assad must go
Obama's gone Assad is still there it is
embarrassing to admit that Assad has won
but 5 million Syrian refugees and
500,000 dead Syrians from the war
already know that right so the fact that
we're cutting and running it wasn't as
if the United States had the leverage on
the ground that was the Russians that
was the Iranians that was the Turks
those were the countries that were
willing to commit a lot because Syria
mattered as as a high priority of
foreign policy to those countries for
the United States it did not and for
someone like President Trump who has
been saying I want to get these guys out
the interesting thing is he waited for
two years obviously Matt a secretary and
others have a lot less influence today
they did before but it's not that this
is such a surprise
why is he why do you call it cutting and
running why not say that the military
has done its job it has virtually
eliminated the Caliphate that the
argument to stay is just to make sure it
doesn't grow back what are our national
security interests there that is a very
good question and the average American
has not had a good answer for that or in
Afghanistan or in the Iraq war right I
mean the fact is that if you go and look
near military bases those were people
and Families
that voted for Trump they voted for
Bernie Sanders they weren't voting for
Hillary
they weren't voting for Jeb they don't
like the idea that we're fighting these
wars on the back of the poorest the
least privileged they come back they're
not heroes we don't take care of them
right so as it as many people as
complain that Trump hasn't actually gone
and visited troops in war zones how
about not having war zones but I wasn't
looking for the political answer to that
I was actually asking for what is as
your expert then what is our national
security interests in Syria
well is this a gift to President Putin
that Trump has given Putin I would argue
the gift came from Obama frankly it was
when the United States said yes we're
gonna get rid of this guy and then a
chemical weapons that's a red line and
then we didn't use it um certainly Putin
welcomes the fact that the Americans are
leaving and there are many leaders
around the world including many
historical in the u.s. that say even if
it's in America's interest to leave if
it's leverage that you can use against
the Russians and the Iranians and even
your allies the Turks you shouldn't just
give it to them you should get something
in return okay that's fair even are you
saying it's not such a bad decision but
maybe the way it was executed was not
the way to do it oh there's a question
that Trump Trump is very capable of
doing intelligent things in very stupid
ways and this is one of many examples of
that like you don't want to do it by
tweet you don't want your own national
security team to not know this was your
decision you don't want you know sort of
the allies that are fighting on the
ground in Syria or supporting us with
logistics and Intel to suddenly find out
oh here's a decision that's but we
didn't hear about this during the g20 in
Argentina but itself you're saying no
big deal you know at the margins would
it be better if the Americans was more
more engaged in fighting terrorism
around the world sure but there are so
many other things that we could be doing
with that money and and frankly the
average american democrat republican
indifferent not the foreign policy
establishment but the average american
is not getting a lot of bang for buck
out of being on the ground in syria and
i don't think you'll hear that from any
of the experts but i think it is a
reality still stunning if the Joint
Chiefs of Staff was left in the dark
about this I wish that were stunning
but it's
yeah and thank you you see